we also have you covered tonight the
nevada numbers turning out of course to
be a
very big deal on the national stage
we've had our team
all over it today vanessa murphy is
standing by but let's begin now with joe
moller who was at
election central joe
we're outside of the election center
here in north las vegas we're in a press
conference today we learned that we will
not be learning any new results until
tomorrow morning in another press
conference but these votes were
continued to be counted today nearly 1.2
million votes have been counted so far
as of yesterday the elections department
counted all the early ballots and
all of the in-person election day
ballots what is left are mail
provisional and electronic ballots sent
to residents overseas
the clark county registrar of voters joe
gloria said they are able to process
70 thousand votes a day
we did read mail today that will be
reported tomorrow in alignment with what
the secretary of state is reporting
and we'll have that information tomorrow
on exactly what we have in house
we will also continue to receive mail
the president presidential race is still
too close to call this evening with what
has been processed
so far it is hard to say how many
outstanding ballots are left due to the
fact that every resident
was sent a mail ballot those must be
postmarked by november 3rd and will be
counted through next week
and gloria said there were issues with a
few voting machines and a handful of
observers
who had to be removed but nothing major
and again that press conference like
we've been mentioning will happen
tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock and then
a similar press conference will happen
the days to follow until all these votes
are counted reporting live in north las
vegas i'm joe muller now we'll send it